[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for example in Amish country
Pennsylvania if for buggies come to an
intersection the longest beard has the
right-of-way in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania it is against the law to
take a knee during the theme from Robin
in Beverly Hills California
you must compost your original node in
Fort Lauderdale Florida
shuffleboard disks are legal currency in
the Bronx New York every block must have
at least one man in a tank top
named angel in Cleveland Ohio the next
person who brings a poster of dogs
playing poker to a taping of Antiques
Roadshow will be murdered in Worcester
Massachusetts you are legally required
to refer to Lacroix sparkling water as
gay code
in Red Bank New Jersey it's illegal to
leave more than one oversized hockey
jersey on the front lawn of Kevin
Smith's childhood home we like that one
yeah in Menifee County Kentucky a horse
must tell you if it's a police horse
before you try anything we're in Ozark
Missouri it's illegal for Earl to hog
all the damn coffee medicine give ol
Randy a swig now come on in Guthrie
Oklahoma
if someone says Happy Holidays it's
legal to stick a boot up their freedom 8
and commie ass like Jesus would do if
you live in Sioux City Iowa and your
name is sue it's illegal to sue the city
of Sioux City so sorry sue but if you're
asking can sue sue sue city the answer
is you can't sue sue city sue
and finally in Mobile Alabama it's
illegal for a mall Santa to grope
teenagers unless he's running for Senate
oh ho ho
you